[音楽]
[拍手]
皆さんこんにちは
私は今大学院で日本の古典文学の研究をし
ています
」って言うとよく聞かれるんです
古典文学なんかやって何の役に立つの一体
何のために勉強してるのって
これがなかなか
難しくてこの問いになかなか答えることが
できずにいました
でも最近になって自分がやってる古典文学
を読むっていうことは実は
コミュニケーション人との向き合い方を
考えることにつながってたんじゃないか
そう思うようになってきたんです
今回は私にとって
古典文学がどんな風にコミュニケーション
人との向き合い方につながっていったのか
お話ししてみたいと思います
私がこの日本の古典文学をやり始めるよう
になったのは
古典文学に共感したっていうことが
大きかったように思います
例えば私いろんな作品に出会ってきたん
ですがその一つに
平家物語と出会いました
平家物語の中でも
懸命門院解くこという女性に興味を持った
んです
このトクコっていう人は今から800年
ぐらい前の人で当時はとっても栄えた平家
の一人でした
この平家は平家物語の中の特に後半の部分
で
一族の者たちが皆
壇ノ浦というところで戦いに敗れてそして
海に身を投げざるを得ない状況になって
いくことが描かれています
この時トクホもその壇ノ浦にいました
壇ノ浦は今の山口県の海なんですけどそこ
の船の上にいてそして
船の上から皆一族の者たちそして8歳に
なる特保の子供までも身を投げていきます
トクホも続いて海に身を投げました
しかし
敵の手によって絡め取られてそのまま
引き上げられて生き残ってしまったんです
その後トクコは京都の山奥でヨセを過ごす
ことになります
そこに
後白河法皇という人が訪ねてきます当時の
偉い人です
この法王に向かって徳子はこれまでの自分
の半生を語り始めたんです
その場面でトクコが
微笑んだって書かれてたんです
この微笑み何私は不思議に思いました
だって普通に考えてみたらおかしくない
ですか自分の子供も一族もみんな失って
しまったつらかったであろう半生の話をし
ているはずなのに
微笑んだって書かれてる
この微笑みから何が見えてくるんだろう私
は
疑問を持ちました
そしてこの疑問をどうにかこうにか頑張っ
て解決しようとしていた時ふとこれまで
自分がどんな笑いどんな微笑みを浮かべて
きたかを考えてみたんです
そしたら自分の中にも特化が浮かべた
みたいにその場の状況とか自分が持って
いる感情とかとは不釣り合いな笑みを
浮かべた経験があったとそう気づいたん
です
ここで私はそうか
古典文学には自分の感覚でも通じるものが
あるんだ」って気づいたんです
これが嬉しくて
読んでいくことになりました
でも
古典文学には現代の感覚だけでは
読み解けないことがありました違うところ
があったんです
例えばどういうことって思いますよねそこ
で
有名な昔話にもなっている
一寸法師っていう作品でお話ししてみたい
と思います
一寸法師ってこんな作品でし
たとっても小さく生まれた一寸法師
一寸法師は立身出世を目指して都に登ろう
と決心します
ここで有名なお
椀の船に
箸の会で
ドンブラコトンブラコと皮を登っていく
わけです
一寸法師がたどり着いたのは
京都にある立派なお屋敷
その屋敷にいたお姫様のお供をするように
なった一寸法師はある時お姫様が鬼に襲わ
れそうになった時お姫様を守りました
そして
鬼が残していった打ち出の小槌を振ると
一寸法師の世話
ぐんぐんぐんぐん伸びて立派な若者になっ
てお姫様と
幸せに暮らしました
これがよく知られている一寸法師のお話
です
この一寸法師という作品が初めて見られる
のは今から400年ぐらい前
江戸時代の
御伽草子っていう物語集です
でも面白いことにこの伽草子の一寸法師は
今お話しした物語とはずいぶん違ってるん
です
ちょっとそこをお話ししてみたいと思い
ます
一寸法師が
京都のお屋敷にたどり着いたところから
行きましょう
お屋敷にいたお姫様に一目惚れをした
一寸法師
一寸法師は何やら策略を練り始めました
どうやらお姫様を手に入れたいと思うよう
になったんです
そして一寸法師はある時お姫様のところに
こっそり行って
その口にお米を塗りました
そしてそのまま一寸法師は泣き出したん
です
そこにやってきたのはお姫様の
お父さんお父さんは一寸法師に尋ねます
何をそんなに泣いているんだ一寸法師
一寸法師は答えます
お姫様が私が大切にしていたお米を食べて
しまったのです
見れば確かにお姫様の口にはお米がついて
いる
お父さんはびっくりしてこんな娘どこにで
も連れてってしまってください
お姫様を追い出してしまいました
一寸法師はというとお姫様を手に入れられ
たと
満足そう
こうして一寸法師はお姫様を連れて
旅へ出かけていきます
皆さん
皆さん今お話しした一寸法師がお姫様を手
に入れるためにした行動どう思いました
私最初読んだ時びっくりしたんですよだっ
て思ってた一寸法師と全然違ってなんだか
ずる賢くて悪者みたいなイメージがあった
からです
現代の感覚だと
褒められる行動ではないですよね
でもですねその時代の他の作品読んでみ
たらこんな風にずるそうな人たちたくさん
見つかったんです
となると
果たしてずるいのかって
実は当時の時代の中でも例えば
酒呑童子っていうお話では
武士たちが鬼を退治するために
鬼の信頼を裏切る形で退治していましたし
サルゲンジソウシっていう話では
身分の低いサルゲンジが
身分を偽ることでお姫様を手に入れてい
ましたお姫様とより好きな女性
こんな風に裏切ったり偽ったりずるそうに
思える行動については特に作品では悪い
ように書かれてなかったんです
となると当時の人たちにとって一寸法師は
別にずるいっていう悪い印象ではなさそう
なんです
そこでもう1回おとぎ同士の一寸法師を見
てみました
そしたら
一寸法師が最初からその体の特徴っていう
のが強調されて書かれていってたんですね
例えばお屋敷に仕えることになったって
いう時にはその声と体の小ささっていうの
が
面白いって言われてそれで気に入られてお
屋敷に行くことになったしそれから
鬼を退治した時だってやっぱり自分の体の
小ささをうまいこと使って対峙しました
こんな風に一寸法師のお話では
常にその体の特徴をうまいこと使って
望みを叶えてたんですね
となるとさっきお話ししたお米をこっそり
塗るなんていうのも一寸法師が自分の体の
特徴をうまいこと使った行動じゃないかと
読めてきたんです
こういう風に見ていくと
一寸法師の見え方だんだん変わってきまし
た
当時の人たちにとってはずるいっていう
ような悪い印象じゃなくて
むしろ自分の望みを叶えていくために自分
の特徴をうまく使っていく
知恵として受け止められてたんじゃないか
そんな見方が出てきたんです
ずるいなーっていう現代の感覚だけで
終わらせてたら全然見えてこなかった姿
でし
ここで私はそうかやっぱり現代の感覚では
古典文学には通じない部分があるんだ
読み解けない部分があるんだと実感しまし
た
そしてこの違いを乗り越えて
古典文学を読んでいくためには
自分が自分の価値観とか思い込みは一旦
置いといてまずは当時の人だったらどう
読んだんだろうと当時の読者の立場に立っ
て読んでみる姿勢が必要だと気づいたん
です
古典文学って今よりはるか昔に書かれた
作品ですだから今とは時代も社会も
価値観も生き方も生活様式や言葉だって
全然違ってたんですだから今の自分の感覚
だけでわからないことがあって当然でし
たここまで私がどんな風に古典文学と
向き合ってきたのかそんなお話をしてき
ました
この私の古典文学との向き合いって
そのまま
人との向き合い方にも置き換えられると
思っているんです
最初は自分と同じところがあったって
嬉しくてどんどん仲良くなってでも
付き合っていくうちにだんだん自分と違う
ところが見えてくるそうすると全然
分かり合えないもう関係諦めたいよとか
ぶつかったりすることも
あるそれでも相手とつながっていきたい
違いを乗り越えていきたいって思うとき
大切なのは相手の話をまっすぐに聞いて
自分もそれに応えていくっていう
対話です
この対話で大事なのはさっきまっすぐ聞
くっていう話をしましたがまさに
寸法師で経験したことがつながっています
まっすぐ聞くにはまず自分が思っている
価値観だとか思い込みは一旦置いておく
そして相手の背景にはどんなものがあるん
だろういったいどんな思いでその言葉を
使っているんだろうそんな風に相手側に
寄り添って考えてみるこの姿勢が対話には
必要でした
今お話しした対話のあり方って多分
当たり前の話だと思いますだから何と
当たり前じゃないかって思った人もいると
思いますでもちょっと想像してみてほしい
んです
皆さんの隣に皆さんにとって親しい人が
いるとします
友達でも家族でも
恋人でもご近所の方でも誰でもいいです
皆さんその方のこと全て理解できるって
思いますか
なかなか
首が
縦にも横にも降らないなって思うんです
けど私は
理解できないなって思うんです
だってその人には自分の知らない過去が
あってそして自分の知らない経験をしてい
て自分が見たことない景色を見ているはず
です
だから違う人間そんなことわかってるよっ
て思うんですけど思うんですけどときたま
相手のこと分かった気になっちゃう時って
ありませんか
私はよくあるんです
特に最近ではこの中でオンラインで
コミュニケーション取ること増えてきまし
たよね
ズーム使ったりとか
オンラインでのコミュニケーションて画面
越しに相手の顔が見えているんだけどでも
相手の表情が読み取りづらかったりそれ
から
息遣いが感じ取りづらかったり結構いつに
も増して人とすれ違いやすい人との距離感
が分かりづらくなっちゃったって感じる
ことが増えてきてるんです私の中で
そんな現代において
古典文学は人とどう向き合うべきなのか
どんな風に対話をしていくべきなのか
そしてその対話の大切さそのものそういう
ことを思い出させてくれる
窓になりました
この窓っていうのは皆さんもそれぞれあっ
て私にとっては古典文学だったっていう
ことです
やっぱり私今まだまだ修行中で
窓なんて言いましたけど
まだ思い込みで突っ走っちゃう時があるん
ですよそんな時にいつも古典文学がグイッ
て引き戻してくれるん
ですあなたちゃんと見えてる相手のこと
そこにはあなたの思い込みとか
価値観とかで突っ走って見ちゃうと相手の
姿がすぐ歪んじゃって一寸法師の時みたい
に全然見えなかった相手の本当の姿って
いうのが自分のせいで見えなくなっちゃう
よって
だから寄り添うことが必要だよって
こんな風にいつも厳しく言われるけどでも
その古典文学を通して
寄り添っていって大変だけどその先に人と
つながることの嬉しさも知りました
今日お話ししてきたことそれは対話のあり
方です
古典文学は
寄り添うっていうことが大事でそれで自分
も答えていくのが大事だよっていうお話を
しましたそして今私はここに立っています
最初
古典文学は何の役に立つのってよく言われ
ますって話をしたと思いますまあ役に立つ
とは言えないけどでもここにい
るっていうことも含めてやっぱり
古典文学は人と人とがつながるそこの力に
なると私はそう思うんです
ありがとうございました